[Music]
the animal foundation is under new
leadership after a rough patch that
strained operations and led to a string
of complaints christian casada is
joining us now in studio after sitting
down with the brand new executive
director krista well denise hillary gray
recently came on board as the new
executive director of the non-profit
today she's speaking out to eight news
now about the uphill battle to gain the
public's trust
i do see a really bright future ahead
there is as you mentioned there is work
to be done it's a new chapter for one of
the largest and busiest animal shelters
in southern nevada as hillary gray has
stepped in as ceo of the non-profit
she's quickly addressing some of the
shelter's challenges the staff situation
is a build
you know i mentioned that the staff that
cares right for the animals is now fully
staffed
we have veterinarians again on board and
we'll have more over the next couple of
months gray says the pandemic strange
resources that led to problems she will
address under her watch i am happy to
report that already and wonderful for me
coming in too
that new cleaning and training protocols
have been put in place hopefully we'll
be able to open our public clinic
operations again soon which are very
important to the community the facility
on mojave and harris today appeared
clean while staff attended to some of
the
425 current animals it has including
deborah the potbelly pig
inside curious residents seeking a new
companion while checking out the
facility clean
organized
professional it just seems like a very
well put together place animal advocates
say they're hopeful for gray's success
but add there's still a lot of work
ahead some things in particular we'd
like to see changed you know they have a
lot of systematic issues right now their
adoption process is ridiculous
well gray says community support is
crucial to the animal foundation's
success they're actually looking for
volunteers to help grow their services
as well as their programs we have all
that information available on our
website that's eightnewsnow.com
christian casada is live local now